[Music]
when Nicolas Bourbaki applied to the
American Mathematical society in the
1950s he was already one of the most
influential mathematicians of his time
he'd published articles in international
journals and his textbooks were required
reading yet his application was firmly
rejected for one simple reason Nicolas
Bourbaki did not exist two decades
earlier mathematics was in disarray many
established mathematicians had lost
their lives in the first world war and
the field had become fragmented
different branches used disparate
methodology to pursue their own goals
and the lack of a shared mathematical
language made it difficult to share or
expand their work in 1934 a group of
French mathematicians were particularly
fed up while studying at the prestigious
Ecole Normale Superieure
they found the textbook for their
calculus class so disjointed that they
decided to write a better one the small
group quickly took on new members and as
the project grew so did their ambition
the result was the la mode de
mathématiques a treatise that sought to
create a consistent logical framework
unifying every branch of mathematics the
text began with a set of simple axioms
laws and assumptions it would use to
build its argument from there its
authors derived more and more complex
theorems that corresponded with work
being done across the field but to truly
reveal common ground the group needed to
identify
consistent rules that applied to a wide
range of problems to accomplish this
they gave new clear definitions to some
of the most important mathematical
objects including the function it's
reasonable to think of functions as
machines that accept inputs and produce
an output but if we think of functions
as bridges between two groups we can
start to make claims about the logical
relationships between them for example
consider a group of numbers and a group
of letters we could define a function
where every numerical input corresponds
to the same alphab
output but this doesn't establish a
particularly interesting relationship
alternatively we could define a function
where every numerical input corresponds
to a different alphabetical output this
second function sets up a logical
relationship we're performing a process
on the input has corresponding effects
on it's mapped output the group began to
define functions by how they mapped
elements across domains if a functions
output came from a unique input they
defined it as injective if every output
can be mapped onto at least one input
the function was surjective and in by
jected functions each element had
perfect one-to-one correspondence
this allowed mathematicians to establish
logic that could be translated across
the functions domains in both directions
their systematic approach to abstract
principles was in stark contrast to the
popular belief that math was an
intuitive science and an over-dependence
on logic constrained creativity but this
rebellious band of scholars gleefully
ignored conventional wisdom they were
revolutionizing the field and they
wanted to mark the occasion with their
biggest stunt yet they decided to
publish le monde de mathématiques and
all their subsequent work under a
collective pseudonym Nicolas Bourbaki
over the next two decades for Ibaka's
publications became standard references
and the group's members took their prank
as seriously as their work their
invented mathematician claimed to be a
reclusive Russian genius who would only
meet with his selected collaborators
they sent telegrams in Bourbaki 's name
announced his daughter's wedding and
publicly insulted anyone who doubted his
existence in 1968 when they could no
longer maintain the ruse the group ended
their joke the only way they could they
printed Bourbaki x' obituary complete
with mathematical puns despite his
apparent death the group barring
Bourbaki 's name lives on today though
he's not associate
with any single major discovery Bourbaki
z' influence informs much current
research and the modern emphasis on
formal proofs owes a great deal to his
rigorous methods Nicolas Bourbaki may
have been imaginary but his legacy is
very real for more stories of infamous
imposters check out this video on one of
history's most notorious art forgers or
this video on Prester John the
influential king who never actually
existed
[Music]